in this video i'll give you five of the
best ways to make money in animal
crossing without having to rely on
turnips so anytime you search online for
animal crossing money making tips
every list every video you find will
undoubtedly mention the stock market or
buying and selling turnips and it's true
buying and selling turnips is the most
efficient way to make large amounts of
money
fast in animal crossing but what about
those who maybe don't have time to check
prices multiple times every single day
or don't want to go through the hassle
of waiting in long lines to travel to
other islands or maybe you just forgot
to play on sunday which is the only day
to buy turnips
what are the other ways to make bells
today we're going to go over five of the
best ways to make bells fast and animal
crossing new horizons
people of the internet's retrorecon tour
here if this is your first time visiting
the channel we're all about helping you
connect and share stories with friends
and family through the power of video
games
and lately one of the best games to
connect and share with others has been
animal crossing new horizons now as i
mentioned in the opening today we're
focused on making money without turnips
now let's get started
number one selling fruit so one of the
best ways to start making money even
early on is to sell fruit now this is
going to start off very
simple but there's actually quite a bit
of depth to selling fruit that can net
you even more bells
to get started you simply shake trees
and sell the fruit now if you're new to
the game you may not know that each
island has its own
native fruit the fruit you have on your
island will sell for 100 bells each
at the time of this recording there are
currently six fruits in animal crossing
new horizons
apples cherries coconuts peaches
pears and oranges you can actually get
all fruits on your island by visiting
other islands now the reason you want
more than one fruit on your island is
because
non-native island fruits sell for 500
bells each
with the exception of coconuts which
sell for 250 bells each
still both are quite a big jump from the
100 bells you get with your native
fruits
now if you really want to maximize your
profits rather than immediately selling
any new fruits you obtain
you'll want to consider planting fruits
in the ground instead
after planting those fruits wait three
to four days and that
tree will bear fruit so the one fruit
you planted will end up being three
fruits in three to four days
then you can shake the tree which will
continue to bear fruit over and over
again
every few days it's definitely worth
your time to plant plenty of fruit trees
around your island
number two sell crafted items if you
start to find yourself with an over
abundance of materials such as rocks or
a certain kind of wood
consider crafting them into furniture
before selling
a lot of times players will simply sell
the extra materials but you'll get more
bang for your buck by using your diy
recipes to turn those spare materials
into furniture and don't forget to check
out the hot item of the day at nook's
cranny which
could end up being an item you can craft
which of course will
net you even more bells number three
catching bugs and fish okay look not
gonna lie to you guys this one is my
favorite way of making money in new
horizons for one catching bugs and fish
is just plain fun
i suggest using a guide or app so you
can target specific bugs and fish that
are worth the most
the acnh dot guide app is fantastic
there's also the animal crossing dot
fandom wiki
i've also created graphics that make it
easy to keep track of the new bugs and
fish
i'll include a link to all of these down
in the description below
now you may have the urge to sell your
bugs and fish right away at nook's
cranny but
unless you need the money fast you'll be
much better off by waiting for a visit
from flick or cj
they both pay 50 more than nook's cranny
so where nooks would buy a giant stack
for 10
000 bells flick will pay 15 000 bells
you can also use the nooks cranny
drop-off box overnight when your store
is closed however this is the worst of
the three methods as you'll only get 80
of the standard nooks cranny pricing of
course you can also sell the new sea
creatures which were added to the game
as part of the summer update
however there's no special vendor like
cj or flick to earn even more from your
efforts
and thanks to the recent changes in how
the game handles visitors to your island
you should never have to go too long
without having a visit from flick or cj
number four fossils fossils are a great
way to make money in new horizons and
require surprisingly little effort
the only challenge is to find where
they've spawned on your island
i've heard of as many as six spawning
per day but the most i've ever seen in a
day is
four usually i have at least three on my
island i do recommend you focus on
completing the museum before you start
selling fossils but of course that's
entirely up to you
the prices on fossils vary but it's
almost always worth your time
don't forget you'll always want to have
the fossils assessed first by blathers
at the museum before you take them to
nook's cranny my son actually tested out
a few weeks ago
you can sell the fossils by themselves
before they've been assessed but i think
it only net you something like 200 bells
it's very small
if you're getting value out of these
tips so far guys consider giving this
video a thumbs up
and if you'd like to see more animal
crossing tip videos on the channel hit
that subscribe button down below
and that's gonna take us right into
number five
nukazon this one is different from any
other on the list as you'll be partially
relying on the cooperation of another
human player you see nukazon is an
animal crossing marketplace managed
through discord
you can make lots of money doing tasks
that others may not have the time to do
themselves such as crafting fish bait or
maybe there's a particular furniture
item someone really wants to complete a
set and it just so happens you have the
item they need
there are many different ways to make
money here so if it sounds like
something you're interested in i'd
suggest checking out the link and
scrolling through some of the posts to
familiarize yourself with how things
work there now i have to stress with
this one you
are relying on another human player to
cooperate
and actually follow through giving you
the items or bells required as part of
your transaction
i've heard of some folks getting ripped
off but the vast vast majority of animal
crossing players i've met through my
stream discord reddit etc have all
been great to play and trade with i
should also stress we are not talking
about a real money exchange here we're
talking bells the in-game currency only
it's actually against nintendo's terms
of service to sell in-game goods for
real-world money now it also doesn't
have to be nukazon there are multiple
subreddits and discord groups out there
that do
very similar activities in fact if
you're looking to get started you're
more than welcome to join my discord as
well
i'll include links to all of these down
in the description below so this video
is all about making money without
turnips but now maybe you're curious as
to how turnips in the stock market
actually works in animal crossing
if you're thinking about giving it a try
check out the link on the top right side
of your page right now which is a link
to my full guide for how buying and
selling turnips works and new horizons
and if you're ready to start working
toward that five-star island score then
check out the link on the bottom right
side of your page
that's gonna be it for me today remember
we all have a story to tell
and your story matters thanks so much
for watching